Am I going to do the glasses?
Yeah, we'll do glasses.
You just have to put up with--
This is just gonna be the video.
You will never
see my pupils.
How you doing?
It's me. That one guy.
You probably don't
watch me anymore.
It's fine. I'm still
here, though.
I'm just going to chat
with you today.
What's... How do you do this?
How do you vlog?
Let's start again,
shall we?
SOFT CLAP
That wasn't a very good clap.
HARD CLAP
I went to a party the other day.
I went to my first
party of the year.
It was three days ago.
I am a social butterfly,
I think you could agree.
For a very long period in my life,
I assumed that I didn't like parties,
and rightly so because I went to a fair amount
of parties and I never enjoyed myself.
There were drunk
people all around me
encouraging me to be drunk
and I did not want it.
I always wanted to sit in the
corner and play video games.
That was always the highlight
of any party for me:
if I could find the
Nintendo 64 in the corner
and encourage whoever's it was to hook it up
so I could just play some Mario Kart.
That's the kind of
party I like to have.
There was legitimately one
house party that I went to
where I brought my GameCube
along being like,
"Oh, we could like play Mario Kart together.
Wouldn't that be fun?"
But I "accidentally" left my copy
of Zelda the Wind Waker in there
and spent the evening
playing Zelda
and I had like a little audience
of people watching me as well.
That was the
best party.
I finally came to the realization, though,
that it wasn't parties that I didn't like.
I just never went to parties
with anybody that I liked.
And now, I get to go to parties with people
I do like and it's great. They're very pleasant.
That's a major realization in
my life is that parties can be fun.
Well done, Charlie.
Got there eventually.
I even went as far as to have
alcohol at a party. Not much at all.
I had like that much champagne,
but to me it was a big deal.
I was like, "This is not the
Charlie that I know,
but he's kind of fancy
and maybe I like him."
I still have absolutely zero
interest in getting drunk.
I don't understand the appeal
of that, but as it happens,
you can have a small amount of alcohol
and it makes you feel quite nice
so long as you're very
sensible about it.
Another realization that everyone else
has already had, but here I am having it.
Usually, I plan these things
intensely, very intensely.
I write out a whole script,
but I am too busy.
I'm doing films now.
Keeping up with the YouTubers of
today, daily vlogging and all that.
Nope, not going to do it.
Going to make 11 minute short films
instead because that's nice and easy.
The film I'm trying to make right now is
proving to be harder than the first one,
which was deliberate.
I wanted ot push myself,
but, turns out,
when you try to do something
harder, it's harder.
Well done, Charlie. Just full of
revelations today, aren't I.
But it'll be fine.
It's stressful, but that's
what film making is,
and I am just thrilled
that I get to be doing it.
That is all. Thank you
for clicking on my face.
If you liked this video, I'm not
going to tell you to click like.
You thought it was
coming, didn't you?
You thought
"If you like this--" nope.
If you like this style of video, let me know
because this was super easy to make.
My God, it's kind of nice not
having a script, actually.
It's been a while since I've
done this, but. Okay, bye!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
CHARLIE: That was fun.
I liked that. I want to do more.